CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman is
with us Ricky good morning good morning
Ricky can you help us understand the
endgame here for stormy Daniels and her
attorney because it would appear that
she put herself in significant legal
jeopardy by speaking with 60 minutes
there is no question that she put
herself in significant legal jeopardy
right now that contract that
nondisclosure agreement is valid and it
remains valid unless or until an
arbitrator or a judge declares it
invalid so by going forward knowing that
she has signed a contract for whatever
reason she said she signed by threat or
because she wanted the money doesn't
matter
she still is under a contractual
obligation not to talk although she has
legal arguments to say the contract is
void but what effect could they have
number one we're calling it an affair I
learned on 60 minutes last night that
actually it was a one night so one night
about a one-night stand and she admits
that she lied and you're saying it
doesn't matter that she felt bullied or
she felt threatened cannot affect the
legal proceedings for her she says that
she felt threatened and her story is
very compelling about the unknown man
right coming up and threatening her and
her child in a parking lot but that
threat or alleged threat only means that
that gave her a reason to say look I was
under fear I was under duress that's why
I signed the non-disclosure agreement
well why you signed the non-disclosure
agreement may be irrelevant once you've
signed her lawyer has said repeatedly
the contract is not valid because Donald
Trump didn't sign it a judge or an
arbitrator may differ with that a good
argument for Michael avenatti and stormy
Daniels is that Michael Cohen opened the
door this year by speaking about it it's
one of the problems that has gone on not
only with this situation but many
situations that either involve Donald
Trump or circle around Donald Trump if
there weren't if there was no talk these
issues would not surface so it's
interesting that you say that because
just as Michael avenatti was leaving the
set he said we could depose the
president within the next
stee days and I said why and he said
well they made a pretty big legal
blunder well I think that we there are
two things that Michael avenatti is
talking about number one he is saying
that Donald Trump intervened in this
procedure in California to remove the
case to the federal court why would he
intervene they want it back in
arbitration which by the way the
agreement says it lives in arbitration
and so he's saying he says by
intervening I'm Donald Trump also known
as David Dennison that that's a legal
blunder he's put himself in the middle
whether or not against oppose within 60
days that may be an exaggeration what we
have to look at though I think is much
bigger picture here the question is are
there violations that come out of this
on a nondisclosure agreement and all of
the surrounding brouhaha
that may create an election violation
right that is with the FEC the person
who could be in trouble for that is
Michael Cohen as well as the campaign
that issue may not go away particularly
for special come that's what Rob Robin
Gotti keeps saying it's not that they
had this one-night stand it's the
cover-up that came after it he says
that's what we should focus on is
salacious and interesting as some people
may find this to be absolutely correct
we'll see where it goes I think you mean
thank you always good to have you here
thank you